en kabul los niños no tienen tiempo de
jugar rock ya una niña afgana de 11 años
está agotada pasan los días limpiando
hornos y recogiendo pequeños pedazos de
carbón en una fábrica para ganar algo de
dinero y ayudar a su familia rocchia es
solo una de los cientos de niños
trabajadores en afganistán
trabajar aquí es muy difícil cuando
llego a casa me duelen las manos y me
siento cansada ojalá pudiera estudiar en
lugar de trabajar aquí eso corazón el
doctor los talibanes cumplieron un año
desde que tomaron el control del país
generando una recesión económica que ha
llevado a millones de afganos a la
pobreza extrema un informe publicado el
10 de agosto por seis de silwan dice que
el 97% de las familias luchan por
proporcionar comida a sus hijos y que
las niñas comen menos que los niños
además unicef viene advirtiendo que
afganistán es el peor lugar en el mundo
para nacer los niños se enfrentan a la
mortalidad infantil la malnutrición los
matrimonios forzados y los abusos
sexuales
la mayoría de las familias han perdido
sus ingresos es por eso que no están
permitiendo que sus hijos asistan a la
escuela los padres no pueden pagar el
costo de la vida o no pueden alimentar a
sus hijos por lo que no tienen otra
opción
marcharse la onu dice que la situación
humanitaria en afganistán ha empeorado
con el 72% de las personas viviendo por
debajo del umbral de la pobreza el jefe
de las naciones unidas para afganistán
asegura que se necesitan 2.600 millones
de dólares de ayuda humanitaria o el
invierno que se avecina podría ser
catastrófico para millones de afganos y
sus niños